well Kevin Hart's job hosting the 91st
Academy Awards lasted just two days the
actor and comedian was announced as the
host Tuesday afternoon but overnight
Hart stepped down following an outcry
over previous homophobic tweets and
comments he made during stand-up
routines nearly a decade ago and a
Warner shows us how an Instagram video
from heart only made matters worse and a
good morning good morning hosting the
Oscars has always been one of the
toughest jobs in Hollywood but the
criticism usually comes after the show
less than an hour after Kevin Hart's
announcement a reporter posted screen
grabs of the comedian's old homophobic
tweets and from there a backlash grew
everything about a raccoon says crying
Kevin Hart is known for his unique brand
of comedy a raccoon came to the glass
doors playing on the glass saw me twice
and he's a fixture at the box office
starring and blockbuster hits like
Jumanji we gotta go cannot windows guys
and the ride-along franchise but just
two days after he was announced as host
of the Academy Awards Kevin Hart dropped
out under fire for past homophobic
comments on social media on Twitter last
night he wrote I do not want to be a
distraction I sincerely apologize to the
LGBTQ community it was an abrupt turn
from just hours earlier I've said Who I
am now verse as wellas then I've done it
when a defiant heart took to Instagram
to say he wouldn't apologize I'm not
gonna get to you to go back and tap into
the days of old when I moved on and I'm
in a complete different space in my life
the comedian faced intense criticism
this week after tweets surfaced from
between 2009 and 2011 where he used the
term gay as an insult and called people
homophobic slurs what my biggest fears
is my son growing up and being gay he
made similar comments in his 2010
stand-up special seriously funny every
kid has a gay moment okay every kid but
what happens you got to nip it in the
bud you got to stop it right there
Hart was chosen as the award ceremony
faces a rating slump the show drew a
record low 26 and a half million
viewers last year with host Jimmy Kimmel
a 20% drop from the year before
regardless Academy I'm thankful and
appreciative of the opportunity if it
goes away no harm no foul
in 2015 Hart was asked about his
homophobic jokes by Rolling Stone
magazine he admitted he wouldn't tell
them today because audiences are more
sensitive now in his apology yesterday
he said his goal is to bring people
together adding much love and
appreciation to the Academy I hope we
can meet again
Nora alright Anna thank you